كانت الفرحه قبل شويه نطب السماء من كثر
ما هي فرحانه شو ما بدك تحكي لنا عمري
جاتني بانك اتاك طول الماتش وانا على
اعصابي انتم مو فاهمين يعني هاي مش مجرد
كره قدم بالنسبه لنا احنا بالمغرب
2018 انا من 2018 النهارده واستنى كاس
العالم عشان نرجع اللي صار والحين والحمد
لله وان ينصركم الله فلا غالب لكم طيب
اسالك سؤال كيف كانت الاجواء
الاجواء احنا للاسف كنا همم كنا فستان همم
يعني تقريبا بين الاسبان بس ولكن لا يمنع
انه احنا صرخنا وقوتنا طول الماتش وعملنا
اجواء ما بيناتنا وكانت الحمد لله حتى
صوتي رايح ولكن الوطن هل كان هناك طبول
كان هناك طفول اكيد من الجهتين الحمد لله
احنا كلنا مقطرين على الشبكتين يعني على
الشبكه من هنا والشبكه من هنا كان جنبها
طبول كانها مؤثرين عليها وكان باغي نقول
من هنا راس لافوكا الرجراجي شكرا بزاف قلت
كلمه وكنتي على حق اللاعب رقم 12 اساسي
ومهم وصوتي ها هو خرج هذا اللاعب رقم 12